you took took a year off and I read and
I know if it's true that you've got a
new hobby what's your new hobby
um well I had a couple but one of them
is knitting knitting it's part of my
apocalypse plan you know like were you
gonna buy clothes you got a new so I'm
just getting ready so your is there any
reason you're getting ready for the
apocalypse
oh I just I saw 20 days later when I was
a kid and I started having a zombie
nightmares and then like I just read up
about like global warming and like the
fresh water crisis and you always think
well what would I do in that situation
and then well you would beat the [ __ ]
out of everyone around you take their
stuff that's all give her on to Rousey
that's hey that guy prepared bang you
don't want to be that guy you know I
just want to be able to like have some
like chickens and like animals and I
have a self-sustaining property is it
true you're into this stuff so you have
like a compound a self-sustaining
property well no I know I'm beating
people up so I can get the compound
oh yeah that's yeah ESCA vader's are
expensive so yes i got our like work
first and then then i'm gonna get the
chickens in the buffalo wait a minute
let me get this straight so you're
you're you're fighting career a lot of
what people other people are out there
in your situation and they're flying
around in private jets and they're
getting the Bentley that's not you
you're saving the money to prepare for
the apocalypse yeah I think it's a good
investment you know better than a plane
yeah no plans could be good too if the
zombies come they well know you've run
out of gas okay so you've been I'm just
very curious about this you said you
have like you have self-sustaining
animals on the farm what kind of animals
do you have that you're going to I would
have you would have well I really like
buffalo because they're just they're
cute and I used to be from Jamestown
North Dakota and our tourist trap was we
had like the biggest statue of Buffalo
ever and I was one-one and I think I'll
pack as and make some really good
sweaters they look cozy and so you gonna
have an alpaca you've learned to knit
you're in like a knitting club or
something it's like a knitting slash
drinking Club you ever wake up and you
like what the hell did I knit you know
well I only I only got time to start
something and so it just has continued
on to like this infinite thing and like
I need to get the girls back together to
teach me and begin a new thing or else I
just have like a scarf that goes around
the world right right
you